Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel eternals video all about eros starfox's
character i know you have lots of questions about
what's going on with him was his relationship
with thanos where has he been this whole time so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos they raise so many questions during the
eternals movie there's so much mythology that they
introduced that's brand new to the mcu it's going
to be really cool to see them explore that in all
the future marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movies
careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
movie yet because we'll be talking about the
mid credits scene but during the mid credits scene
after the end of the movie inn teleports pip the
troll and eros thanos's brother they're using the
same type of technology as the bifrost with that
rainbow effect that you see from the thor movies
or avengers infinity war when thor is teleporting
around with stormbreaker pip the troll is being
played by patton oswalt he looks just like he
does in the comics in starfox eros is being played
by harry styles who also looks just like he does
in the comics they arrive with the offer of an
explanation to what happened with their friends
and what's going on with the other eternals around
the universe and the celestials and basically tell
them they're here to team up to help take down the
celestials i know you have all kinds of questions
now about his relationship with thanos what does
this mean about thanos backstory their parents
because there's so many unanswered questions
that they raised during the turtles movie
they're very on the nose and obvious in the way
they reference eros's relationship with thanos
brother of thanos the other eternals even react
by saying wait what what are you talking about
thanos had a brother what do you mean by that
as if very few people inside the mcu knew
that thanos actually had a brother like it
was the secret that thanos tried to keep
but aeros has a version of his red and white comic
book costume he's got the red hair from the comics
and he's another prime eternal like ajak and
cersei prime eternals are just recognized as
the leaders of any of the teams of eternals on
whichever planet they're on and the ones with
those special celestial orbs aeroshem gives those
to the prime maternals to allow them to directly
communicate with him open those celestial zoom
calls but there's a whole lot of extra celestial
technology involved in making those that fastos
use to reverse engineer the unimine bracelets
that's going to be important for later too now
that they have more orbs the idea that there are
more orbs out there they can create more bracelets
to form an even larger unimined and that's sort
of their key to defeating the celestials
or at least fighting them to a standstill
there's this whole theme of apex predators that
runs throughout the eternals movie like there's
always a bigger fish out there and they want you
to think that the celestials are the biggest apex
predators in the mcu right now but we all know
that galactus exists galactus would be the true
apex predator you can just imagine him snacking
on all those celestial seeds on different worlds
i'll do a longer video about galactus and how he
figures into all this too because technically he's
not a celestial he's a little bit different but
the suit that eros is wearing the armor is the
exact same technology as the suits that the other
eternals wore in the movie just confirming that
he's an eternal just like them which also means
that thanos his brother is an eternal just like
them although there are some differences because
they were born biologically to parents on titan
patton oswalt's pip the troll here is basically
just meant to be a comic book version of the
character he was kind of created to be this joke
jester style character most people remember him
from the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline but
he kind of popped up through a lot of different
space-based stories he jokes about not teleporting
drunk anymore because usually when he shows up in
the comics he's drunk the funny thing about
aeros's origin story is that he showed up for
the first time in an iron man comic book
of all places iron man number 55 in 1972
pip the troll appeared for the first time in an
adam warlock story in 1975 we're actually going
to meet mcu adam warlock during guardians of the
galaxy 3. finally james gunn just confirmed that
he'd be played by will poulter so eventually we
might see some adam warlock in eros starfox cross
over when pip the troll calls eros a prince of
titan that's because his and thanos's father alars
mentioned by red skull during avengers infinity
war was the prime eternal of titan the leader of
their people so that's who eros would have gotten
his special celestial orb from before his father
died they kind of referenced that during avengers
infinity war but it's with sad overtones because
thanos laments the destruction of titan like it
was beautiful once when pith the troll says that
eros is the defeater of black roger and he's from
mystery planet that's just from a story called
the comedy of eros in the classic comics where he
saved a girl from a villain named black roger on
mystery planet using some creative teleporting the
fact that they jump onto the domo the ship here
all surprise like and find them it's just meant
to be a reference to that creative teleporting
is also meant to foreshadow how they're going to
save the other eternals from the world forge with
some creative teleporting but after he drops all
those pickup lines to athena's character oh you're
so beautiful just like i've heard he tells them
that he's going to use his special orb to help
find the other eternals arishem the judge at
the world forge and the reason why they go out
on the foreigner song is just a reference to his
powers and the other eternals starting another
new mission again this time without having their
memories wiped in the comics aeros's whole power
is stimulating the pleasure centers of people's
brains that's why everyone is joking posting memes
saying he has horny powers the reason why harry
styles of all people big pop stars playing eros
is because chloe zhao the eternals director
picked him specifically for the part and said
it was mostly because of his performance during
dunkirk but she'd been watching some of his acting
performances recently you've probably seen harry
styles has been doing more and more movies i don't
really have an issue with them casting someone
like him as long as the execution of his character
in the future works out the idea is that he'll be
back in eternals 2 and that's when they'll cover
the majority of this irish and judge world forged
celestials plot post all the doctor strange memes
eternals 2 we've come to bargain and if we're
talking about the origin of the celestials and
the way they lie about the origin of the universe
there is the idea that eternity is the one that
created the celestials they referenced the term
eternity several times during the movie but they
never talk about eternity as if it's an actual
character in the mcu so we'll see how they handle
that in future movies i think they'll probably
save a lot of that for future eternal sequels
just because it's such a big concept i think they
wanted to kind of wade in as slowly as possible
but the whole relationship between eros and thanos
his brother is very classic family drama very
recognizable they've changed their backstories and
the eternals backstories a little from the comics
but originally all the eternals came from earth
and they started out as regular humans that the
celestials modified they weren't cosmic robots
or anything like that because they weren't robots
they always had the ability to have children but
over millions of years the very first eternals
had children then grandchildren so ikaris makkari
druig thena phastos ajak all the main characters
in the movie are like the grandchildren of those
original eternals at some point during the second
generation of eternals they had their own version
of a captain america civil war event and a group
of them left earth to go colonize other planets
one of these groups went to titan then over
millions of years there were more subsequent wars
that devastated that planet and eventually thanos
and eros's father a'lars left earth and went
to help rebuild titan with one of the survivors
of those many wars there sui-san thanos and
eros's mother together the two of them helped
repopulate the planet titan and the eternals
that lived there were then called titans that's
why thanos is called the mad titan but they're
all still eternals just like the ones on earth
thanos is the older brother when he's born he's
born with the deviant syndrome that's why he looks
like the purple space grimace with the nutsack
chin eros his younger brother is born without any
kind of defect so he looks just like the other
eternals on titan there was some deleted scenes
from avengers infinity war with some concept art
that they produced for thanos's parents they were
going to do a flashback with young thanos make all
the jokes about thinos that you want because he's
not all swole here they just chose to remove this
and just do the backstory the way they showed you
during the actual titan scene in the movie if
you've read any of thanos comic book backstory
there's this whole idea that the cosmic entity
death became his companion as a child and sort
of manipulated him into becoming who he was
in present day and set him on his quest to
kill half the universe in the mcu movies they've
never done any of that thanos and death backstory
he just grew up being ostracized by his peers
because of his appearance because kids will
make fun of anything that looks different then
later he was dubbed the mad titan after he came
up with his final solution to balance the planet
and save it by killing half the population the mcu
reason why their parents elars and swisson were
probably able to have children even though they're
celestial robots just like the other eternals
is probably because of a similar sprite style
twist at the end of the movie cersei uses the
cosmic power of the unimine to transform sprite
something similar probably happened to thanos
parents that allowed them to conceive children
but the idea is that mcu thanos and eros are both
eternals but they're slightly different they've
been modified because of the way their parents had
been modified allowing them to even have them in
the first place that's probably one of the reasons
why the celestials didn't act to stop thanos
because they weren't able to track him through
space because of the changes to his physiology
the same thing with eros as well but thanos's
father was the one who banished him from titan
before it was destroyed it's implied that at some
point before the final destruction of the planet
his brother eros also left the planet and that's
how he's still alive today but i think they'll use
future eros cameo scenes wherever he shows up in
movies to explain more of this backstory of titan
in thanos backstory there have been rumors about
them doing more with other versions of the thanos
character in future movies like they explain
aeros backstory and that's an opportunity to do
young thanos during avengers infinity war thanos
is about a thousand years old so eros would just
be a couple years younger than that the reason why
thanos never spoke about his brother is probably
mostly out of resentment and bitterness from their
childhood in terms of power levels normally they'd
be pretty evenly matched without any weapons but
older thanos just got so swole during his conquest
to balance the universe i would say infinity war
thanos could beat eros in a bare-knuckle brawling
match if aeros wasn't using his psychic powers
but for those of you asking what has eros starfox
been doing this whole time in the mcu while thanos
was going around balancing the universe snapping
everyone well one he was probably staying as far
away from thanos as possible and trying to craft
a plan to defeat the celestials and just having
random adventures because in the comics he is kind
of a comedic character just having all kinds of
hornball adventures do not be surprised if harry
styles eros character cameo scenes in other future
movies space-based movies like guardians of the
galaxy 3 captain marvel 2 the nova movie silver
surfer movie maybe fantastic four sequels but if
you have any other questions about what's going on
with harry styles eros character just let me know
in the comments below or about thanos backstory
i've got a couple other eternals bonus videos
that i'm working on so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that
my hawkeye episodes will also start in a couple
weeks too everyone click here for my full eternals
post credit scene video and click here for my full
breakdown of the entire movie with easter eggs for
everything thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!